welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and marvel studios finally unveiled
their path forward in phase five in
phase six and it is through kang with
jonathan majors put in the nasty and
kang dynasty as we now embark on this
road to secret wars attendees at san
diego comic-con were shown exclusive
footage for ant-man the was quantum
mania revealing the true kang the
conqueror after his variance debut in
loki i
paved
the road you
you just walked down it yes walked past
tense the road we have all been on this
whole time in the mcu was steamrolled by
this self-described jerk and now we're
gonna find out what exactly he meant by
that and what his plan is through
fantastic four kang dynasty and secret
wars so i'm going to break down what
this quantum mania footage was and how
this film will point to our new
destination at the end of all time the
back to back avengers films of 2025 kang
dynasty and secret wars who will be
fighting in those battles so kevin feige
confirmed that marvel phase 5 is
beginning with ant-man the was quanah
mania coming february 2023 quanamania
really being the midpoint of the current
multiverse saga that will lead into
phase six with fantastic four november
8th 2024 followed by avengers the kang
dynasty on may 5th 2025 and avengers
secret wars on november 7th 2025. phase
four has really been some infinity saga
reactive coasting with hints at this
journey with he remains in loki just
wait
until you meet my
variants and lines from jim halpert and
multiverse of madness the larger the
footprint you leave behind the greater
the risk of an incursion
encouraging an incursion occurs when the
boundary between two universes erodes
and they collide
destroying one
or both
entirely but now quantum mania will
firmly lock us in on a clear trajectory
towards this next endgame so let's break
down exactly what happened in the
quantum mania footage at comic con it
starts with scott lang saying do i miss
the action sometimes will i be there
when the avengers need me absolutely but
right now the only job i want is being a
dad i love you cassie thanks for being
my hero and for the rest of you kids out
there a word of advice look out for the
little guy and we learned that scott is
at a book reading for his new memoir
look out for the little guy we also know
from ms marvel that scott had a podcast
called big me little me on this powered
life which is how apparently the world
learned about the events of infinity
ward in game but then scott's phone
rings and he asks why is jael calling
then he bails out his daughter cassie
lange now recast as katherine newton and
he tells her look i get it i do cassie i
really do you want to help but i know
how much you're wasting your life but
then cassie shoots back at least we're
trying to do something that matters yes
we suggesting that cassie might be now
stature leading the young avengers and
that's what landed her in jail but scott
responds i literally saved the world and
then hank pym mocks oh did you you never
mentioned that before everybody scott
saved the world then hope vandyan joins
in the laugh oh is that right scott you
should write a book about it and scott
says ha ha hilarious you're welcome for
you all not being dust next we hear
jonathan major's voice over it's kang he
says you're an interesting man scott
lang you've lost a lot of time but time
isn't what you think it's not a straight
line referring to scott lang time
dilating ahead five years in endgame
missing out on cassie's formative years
then cassie gets sucked into some bright
blue light then the adults re-enter the
quantum realm kang's voice goes on when
you can see time the way i do you can
see everything and we see some residents
of the quantum realm civilization some
of them cranking large disks mounted to
a wall we see bill murray's character
who says janet van dyne i thought you
were dead suggesting he might have been
some boyfriend of hers while she was
down with quantum realm and then kang's
voiceover continues your reality
everything you're holding on to
everything you call a life i know how it
ends and some footage shows spinning
discs and bands machinery rotating
around kang that all eventually lock
into place to form a platform that he
strolls across this montage also
includes a brief shot of modoc's angry
purple face some rumors that cory stole
as darren cross from the 2015 film might
have been deformed during his time in
the quantum realm into what we now know
as modoc in the comics mechanized
organism designed only for killing the
giant headed hover chair seated
hilarious jerk from aim i've done a few
videos on the channel about this guy and
how he might actually show up in ant-man
the was gonna mania and this footage
ends with scott lang saying um i don't
know who you are but you've made a big
mistake i'm an avenger and kang finally
shows his face saying you're an avenger
have i killed you before and with that
one calm smug question kang lays out
everything he's been up to kevin feige
confirmed that the multiverse saga is
all kang's doing saying there's nobody's
shoulders i'd rather be putting the
multiverse saga on than his it's really
impressive that jonathan majors is able
to do all the different incarnations
variants if you will of kang that we
will see him do it's really pretty cool
so what did kang mean by all these
things kang tells scott that time is not
a straight line referring to the sacred
timeline that we saw in loki which was
depicted orbiting around the citadel in
a curved loop meaning that for kang and
for his variants all of history unfolds
all at once time is made up of a tightly
coiled loop of countless histories
playing over and over and over again
kang has lived through them all he knows
how it all ends and how it all begins
and that includes we now know histories
in which he has killed avengers this man
has killed so many avengers over so many
different timelines that he cannot
remember if scotland was one of them
it's also kind of a diss at scott lang
because you know even broadway producers
don't know whether or not scotland was
in a battle or not now every single one
of these sacred timeline coils has their
own variant of kang these kangs in the
comics collectivize in an assembly known
as the council of kangs also the kang
dynasty they gather in these big arenas
and just kind of shout over each other
in the locate season one finale he
remains suggested that many of his past
variants when they were still the 31st
century scientist nathanael richards
went to war with each other until only
he was left he who remains but that
wasn't necessarily a war against keng's
kangs was really a war among nathaniel's
that led to he remains he who remains
variants now are presumably the other
winners of such wards who live on as
part of this collective of kangs so when
you kill one kang variant there's always
another one somewhere out in the time
stream to take his place thus an endless
dynasty of rulers a kang dynasty so why
is kang important to this story ant-man
the was quantum mania well notice how
kang tells scott you've lost a lot of
time scott lang time dilated while he
was in the quantum realm but janet van
dyne did not during her time there she
just aged normally over 30 years why was
that the case well that's because while
scott was in the quantum realm he also
stumbled into a time vortex which is a
separate structure within the quantum
realm notice how janet told scott and
don't get sucked into a time vortex we
won't be able to save you which means
during janet's time in the quantum realm
she and bill murray were aware of these
things called time vortexes but knew to
stay away from them they just aged
normally in the quantum realm and never
went to a time vortex now as we have
learned more about realms dimensions
universes and timelines in the mcu i
think the quantum realm is an example of
a buffered dimension between universes
and between timelines that all universes
and points in time share a border with
and a time vortex i believe is an
artificial construction built by someone
to create a waypoint in the border of
the quantum realm to various points in
time the avengers used these waypoints
in endgame to navigate to specific
points in the past tony stark helped him
do so by discovering the code to quantum
navigation using an inverted mobius
strip mobius remember also being the
name he remains gives one of his
ancients so i think what tony unlocked
there was actually the first piece of a
puzzle that the kangs will inevitably
design in fact the rotating mechanisms
that kang uses in this quantum media
footage may be his clockwork as the
engineer of the vortexes that the
avengers hijacked to complete the time
heist so when he remains said i paved
the road he was absolutely including
everything the avengers did including
the time heist that's why he remains tva
had that [ __ ] loophole for what the
avengers did you have the wrong person
oh really and who should we have
i suspect the avengers we're not here to
talk about the avengers oh no no
what they did was supposed to happen you
escaping was not ah he remains therefore
wanted the avengers to go back in time
to gather the infinity stones and undo
what thanos did but the question is did
he remains design his sacred timeline
that way in spite of his other kang
variants or did he do it with their
knowledge and with their consent are
they all together is he remains a
representative of the rest of the kangs
or is he a rogue to this dynasty i think
he was a rogue i think he remains was
hiding from the other kangs because
notice he was so scared of his other
variants if you think i'm
well
just wait
till you meet my
variants and then after sylvie kelsey
remains another kang variant comes in
with a noticeably different management
style he remains was probably not on the
same page as that other kang now if
you're full of chivalry and really want
to address someone as lord and lady
established titles can make it official
established titles is a project based on
a historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
lords and ladies in english they let
people buy as little as one square foot
of dedicated land so they can call
themselves a lord or lady and in return
established titles commits to planting a
tree it's just a really fun way to help
preserve the beautiful woodlands and
biodiversity of scotland while
supporting global aforestation efforts
established titles work with global
charity trees for the future and one
tree planted to help them plant a tree
for every order plus for those with
scottish heritage out there it's just a
great way to connect to your family
roots your certificate features a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land on a private
estate in edelston scotland and an
official certificate with a crest you
can get a couple pack for you and your
partner with adjoining plots of land and
you can literally have this gift ready
in five minutes so what makes an amazing
last minute gift and established titles
is actually running a massive sale right
now plus if you use the code new
rockstars you get an additional 10 off
so go to
establishtitles.comrockstars to get your
gifts now and help support this channel
and that statue i assume represents the
versions of kangs that we're now meeting
in quantum mania compared to the puck
like rascal we met in loki this is the
more menacing self-serious kang the
conqueror whom he remains alluded to
i've been dubbed many
names by many people
a ruler
a conqueror
he who remains
a jerk and i think this kang the
conqueror and quantomania has come to
collect a toll for the avengers
hijacking his time vortexes that he
built into the quantum realm so what
made he remains at a sacred timeline
different in this multiverse what has
made 616 unique is that it is the one
timeline where a kang allowed this
timeline's avengers to slip away and
break the rules of time travel every
other universe i think the avengers are
eventually caught up to by that kang and
undone murdered by kangs like the one we
meet in quantomania now one of the few
other dimensions we know about in the
mcu is 838 those heroes won their
infinity war without ever needing to
discover time travel via quantum
navigation 838 reed richards was aware
of the multiverse and incursions and yes
his portal is based on the visual of dr
doom's time platform but that
illuminati's concept of the multiverse
is really grounded in sorcery and
dreamwalking there is no indication that
they were time travelers but in 616 he
who remains kept these avengers safe and
to begin to unlock the secrets of time
why did he do that i think he did that
as a failsafe against his rival kang's
if anything ever happened to him and now
that something has happened to him
sylvie stabbed him the damn has been
burst and the 616 avengers are in that
nightmare scenario where they have to
face his variants the full might of the
kang dynasty but the good news is he who
remains left them with the keys to fight
back against the dynasty so that they
don't have to die nasty the 616 avengers
have access to quantum time travel
technology as far as i know hulk still
has that device so ice and quantum mania
will end with scott lang thwarting this
kang or they're at least able to escape
the kang that loki has to deal with in
season two but scott lang will quickly
learn how impossible kang is to kill
since he's really part of a dynasty
infinite whackamoles who can infinitely
respawn so i think the general game plan
in phase 5 will be similar to what the
infinity saga did with thanos the
infinity stones a gradual rollout title
by title to just show in little ways how
kang has influenced all parts of marvel
history through his various identities
sparrow rama tut immortus or any other
alias he's been using actually since
we're already in the multiverse saga we
may have already been seeing this
process unfold in moon night we saw an
image of fero-rama tut on the back of a
jacket worn by a guy in cairo implying
that ferrorama tut existed in egyptian
history in 616. we could see this in
future titles like blade this movie
could drop a line about how sir percival
found the ebony blade in the tomb of an
egyptian pharaoh maybe i got the coven
of chaos could talk about how the
darkhold found its way to agatha's coven
in the 1600s from a figure named
immortus these are just ones i'm
spitballing but the mc is now perfectly
set up to just show how every weird
thing about the mcu could have been
kang's doing every plot hole from bruce
banner's suddenly changed appearance of
edward norton to mark ruffalo-esque to
recently the statue of liberty going
from bronze to green once more between
noah home and ms marvel when ms marvel
definitely takes place after spider-man
no way home all of this could be
justified as evidence of kang altering
things within his matrix so this is
gonna lead to a fantastic four film in
november 2024 the main events of which i
don't think will be focused on kang
specifically more likely it's gonna be a
story about the fantastic four and
doctor doom but i do think in that movie
will be at least one moment where reid
richards learns that his descendant in
the 31st century will be nathaniel
richards the cause of pain for so many
throughout the multiverse i think at
this point as mcu transitions into phase
six we'll get a young avengers title one
of those mystery dates on the phase six
schedule because one of those characters
is iron lad who is a young nathaniel
gets displaced from time and tries to
avert his future as kang so avengers the
kang dynasty is gonna be the payoff of
this kang crescendo as we see the ways
kangs have dominated other timelines by
killing avengers a bloodbath so
widespread that the kang in quantum
media couldn't even remember if he had
killed a scott lang before or not i
think the kang dynasty has got to be
another crossover event the way infinity
war was one that ends in a major
cliffhanger it's not just gonna be
whatever the membership of the avengers
is at that point we're gonna get other
groups like the fantastic four and the
mutants joining them in a battle through
time to prune or unprune each of the
ways the kangs have manipulated history
yes this does sound like a time heist
part two and before you say that you've
been time traveled out just imagine a
story that is wholly thematically
dedicated to that and rather than one
that tries to do something different
than endgame just doubles down on it
think about it a story where marvel
heroes add layer upon layer to the
specific events of the time heights we
saw in act 2 of end game several
different ant-man's ben and over asking
to be flicked flick me when the
tesseract suitcase slides to the beat of
loki and that loki takes it and zips
away off into the loki's series maybe in
this case that branch timeline gets
averted and the suitcase slides to the
feet of one of the kings but then it
gets snatched away by reed richards who
then slingshots it over to nightcrawler
who grabs it and teleports to
westchester where now he finds sitting
in the wheelchair is a whoops another
kang so they gotta reset and do it again
whatever the main timeline mechanics of
the kang dynasty look like i think the
route to defeating all of these kangs
will be the way any dynasty ends from
the inside the avengers the fantastic
four and the x-men will have to turn the
kangs against each other make deals with
some to take out the others maybe make
sacrifices to prune a hero's own origin
to defeat a particular kang they could
simplify it and the kang dynasty film
will just present six or seven
particularly nasty kangs that the team
has to work to undo and defeat one by
one that could give that movie a kind of
nice epic structure the way that
infinity war was just a series of
battles over each stone and kind of a
treasure hunt that way but you could
also compare this to something like kill
bill or scott pilgrim versus the world
at the end of it all will be one final
kang because there's always one final
kang kang prime that is the kang that in
the comics sits at the end of all time
really benefiting from all the other
kangs that are warring against each
other and that kang i think in the mcu
is going to be the lord of battle world
as basics comes to its conclusion and
avengers secret wars now the 2015 secret
war storyline has dr doom as the villain
who gathers all the marvel heroes and
villains together on a multiversal
landscape to fight each other and while
i think doom is definitely on his way
into the mcu soon i think they're gonna
want to save him as a villain for phase
seven hey seven oh god how are we
already here but yes in secret wars i
think kang prime is gonna use battle
world to trap these marvel heroes in one
sandbox and play them against each other
the way they played the kings against
each other kevin feige was asked about
secret wars by josh horowitz from mtv
news endgame was so huge secret wars has
been talked about can you go bigger is
that important to kind of be on that
scale it's not it's never about going
bigger just to go bigger sometimes by
the nature of the number of characters
that you have in the toy box to then
bring into the sandbox of the story
things can get bigger ah there it is
toybox versus sandbox the way to raise
the stakes is not another universe
breaking threat it's really the mix of
assets that he has access to secret wars
is the event where kevin feige likely
hopes to get all of the toys back in the
sandbox that's what makes secret war
special in the comics it's 616 versus
1610 and boy golly do i hope we get
miles morales in this event i think
they'd have a pretty good argument to
get robert downey jr to come back and
chris evans to come back scarlett
johansson but if the mcu secret wars is
616 versus 838 a universe word patrick
stewart with charles xavier by that
logic might also mean that hugh jackman
is wolverine that universe james mars
did his cyclops in that universe we're
not exactly sure i just think the fact
that kevin feige wants to do secret wars
as the next big event that they're
working towards it's gonna be a
culmination of his own career and the
first marvel film that kevin feige
worked on was the 2000 x-men i think the
secret war that gets fought in the mcu
is gonna be between the avengers we grew
up with and the x-men we grew up with
that'll break the sandbox now i
obviously don't work at marvel yet the
kang plans they're likely considering
are as countless as kang variants
themselves i just think this one is the
one that makes the most sense to me but
comment down below with what you think
of it follow me on instagram and twitter
avos follow new rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you